seguramente algunas veces he escuchado
que un avión tenga como un límite de
velocidad marc dos más dos
o tal vez hayas escuchado en alguna
película de ciencia ficción nosotros
viajaremos a una velocidad de mach
1.8 por ejemplo y bueno con un poco de
sentido común podríamos concluir que el
número de mar habla de una cierta clase
de velocidad entonces este número habla
acerca de una cierta velocidad
pero no es cualquier tipo de velocidad
estamos refiriéndonos a una comparación
con la velocidad del sonido es decir el
número más hace alusión a un múltiplo oa
una fracción de la velocidad del sonido
por ejemplo si nosotros decimos que
vamos a una velocidad de mach 2 no
estamos refiriendo que vamos a 2 veces
la velocidad del sonido nosotros
viajamos a 2 veces la velocidad del
sonido
pero en ese mismo medio y con esas
mismas condiciones en ese mismo medio y
con las mismas condiciones y es que
estas dos últimas afirmaciones dicen
cosas muy importantes en ese mismo medio
y con las mismas condiciones se refiere
a que la velocidad del sonido no es la
misma depende del medio es decir la
velocidad del sonido cambia si estamos
en el agua o si estamos en el aire o si
estamos en la atmósfera y es que la
velocidad del sonido depende de la
densidad del medio en donde viaje y
dense cuenta que por eso también se
pueden desde la altitud no es lo mismo
como viaje el sonido al nivel del mar o
como viaje al sonido a una altitud
superior donde los gases son distintos
por ejemplo a nivel del mar y ojo a una
temperatura de 20 grados celsius el
sonido viaja a 340 metros sobre segundo
o en su dado caso escrito en millas por
hora esto es lo mismo que 760 millas por
hora y quiero que se den cuenta que yo
les comenté acerca de que estábamos de
grados centígrados porque la velocidad
del sonido también depende de la
temperatura por ejemplo si la
temperatura baja si la temperatura
desciende entonces la velocidad del
sonido también va a descender la
velocidad del sonido también baja y si
la temperatura sube pues la velocidad de
sonido también va a aumentar por lo
tanto si alguien les dice que un objeto
va a más 2 de velocidad
entonces ese objeto viaja a 2 veces la
velocidad del sonido pero ojo también
encenderá que decir en qué medio está y
bajo qué condiciones se encuentra es
decir presión temperatura etcétera en la
mayoría de los casos cuando se viaja a
velocidades tan grandes como esta o
superiores se viaja a una altitud muy
grande porque a estas alturas la
densidad del aire disminuye y estamos a
un poco menos de 20 grados centígrados
por lo tanto no te dejes engañar si
alguien te dice que está viajando a
matos no forzosamente está viajando a
680 metros sobre segundos oa 1520 milla
va a depender de en qué altitud de este
que por cierto en altitudes muy grandes
la velocidad del sonido disminuye es un
poco menor que 340 metros sobre segundo
pero entonces a partir de aquí cada vez
que oigas que una persona rompe un
récord en términos del número de marc se
están refiriendo a que rompió el récord
en múltiplos la velocidad del sonido que
recuerden que el nivel del mar es 340
metros sobre el segundo o 760 millas por
hora y bueno también si ustedes se
preguntan qué tiene que ver todo esto
con la persona que tenemos en la foto de
la izquierda que yo corte y pegue de
wikipedia pues él es ernest + 10 por eso
que esta cantidad se llama el número
marx ernst + aquel que fue un filósofo y
un físico austriaco que trabajó en
múltiples ocasiones con ondas de choque
cuando ondas de sonido y muchos
problemas más en honor a él se llama el
número mar de esta manera